hola de nuevo bueno aquí tenemos una
gráfica en una gráfica que claramente es
una función trigonométricas y vamos a
averiguar qué funciones entonces vamos a
analizar esto lo primero que yo hago
cuando veo algo así es primero quiero
averiguar cuál es el periodo y amplitud
ahora cuál es su amplitud esa es una
fácil de responder entonces la amplitud
bueno eso simplemente es cuánto se mueve
hacia arriba y hacia abajo del eje de
las equis entonces amplitud aquí vemos
que se mueve un medio sobre y debajo del
eje de las equis por lo tanto la
amplitud la amplitud es un medio y bueno
lleva en mente que la amplitud no es no
es toda esta distancia no no es todo
esto solo es cuánto avanzas sobre el eje
de las equis y debajo el eje de las
equis entonces en este caso la amplitud
es un medio luego tenemos que averiguar
cuál es el periodo el periodo es cuánto
tarda cuántos radial es la cantidad de
radiales para que complete un ciclo y
bueno si estamos aquí seguimos si
estamos aquí
la gráfica no es hasta que llegamos a
este punto cuando se completa un ciclo
porque aquí aquí aún vemos que va hacia
abajo
entonces no lo estamos repitiendo y acá
ya se empieza a repetir luego se vuelve
a repetir justamente acá entonces cada
cada pie radiales empiezas nuevamente el
ciclo pasa lo mismo si vas hacia atrás
en los radiales negativos entonces el
periodo aquí es pi
de hecho podrías empezar en cualquier
punto si empiezas por ejemplo en este
punto y sigues la gráfica llegas a este
otro punto y nuevamente puedes ver que
el periodo espí ahora hay que averiguar
si ésta es una función seno coseno
entonces bueno por ahora no vamos a
pensar en traslación no pensaremos
solamente bueno en que pasa cuando
queremos saber qué funciones está fx fx
es igual a es un misterio no sabemos
vamos a averiguar eso y bueno podemos
ver que f de cero f de cero es igual a
cero entonces que que nos dice eso es
una función se no es una función coseno
qué es el coste no de cero el coste de
cero es uno cierto sí entonces bueno el
seno de cero es cero así que aquí
sabemos que estamos hablando de una
función seno sabemos que la función la
fórmula tendrá la forma la fórmula
tendrá la forma lo voy a escribir acá
tendrá la forma fx es igual a la
amplitud por el seno de dos pi seno de
dos pi sobre el período x y si hacemos
la sustitución de estos números sabemos
que fx
fx es igual a un medio por el seno de
dos pin seno de dos pisos sobre pío x
entonces pi sobre peak se cancelan y
obtenemos que fx es igual
es igual a un medio
me dio seno de 2x seno de 2x y ahora
sólo por curiosidad definamos otra
función hay que definir la función a ok
hee x gdx es igual a un medio
coseno de 2x entonces bueno como como se
verá esto o que a la gramática está muy
difícil en éste
como lo digo bueno hay de hecho aquí me
equivoqué porque lo hice en rosa y
también la función está en rosa
pero bueno entonces voy a circular esto
esto es esta función de aquí y bueno ok
am cuando x es igual a cero que es g de
0 g de 0 pongamos 0 aquí entonces todo
esto se hace 0 que es el coste no de 0
que es el coste no de cero es 1 cierto
entonces uno por un medio es simplemente
un medio por lo tanto g de cero es un
medio y empezaríamos aquí luego
tendríamos justo como una función seno
tendríamos un periodo de pi porque
porque tiene el mismo coeficiente así
que esto se mirará se va a mirar algo
así algo así creo que que ya te estás
dando la idea de cómo va este asunto
bueno es como es como la función seno
pero simplemente trasladado a la
izquierda es como bueno no no te quiero
de hecho confundida así que mejor mejor
borra todo esto
e ignora lo importante es importante
darse cuenta que gente que corta el eje
de la sien no en uno sino en un medio y
bueno la razón por la cual no te lo
corta en uno aún cuando cuando costero
de cero es uno es porque tenemos este
coeficiente de un medio un medio por la
función coseno hoy bueno espero te
espero que ésta te haya dado esto una
idea de una mejor idea de cómo mirar una
gráfica y seas capaz de averiguar su
ecuación así que hay otro vídeo a muy
pronto
en el módulo de khan academy sobre
gráficas de trigonometría nos vemos
pronto bye